buongiorno dottoressa comodi poi vediamo
questo album fotografico è che belle
ecografie che abbiamo qui noto la
presenza di stafilococco sa se che
poteva avere provocato da sempre fine
delle giacoia allora via spiego in
manier che anche un minus habens come
lei possa comprendere e medico per caso
ma perché le cose che io sono il medico
del paziente quindi che gentilmente mi
fa finire di parlare grazie allora
praticamente il suo destino come un
treno viaggia ad alta velocità in
perfetto orario ma può tempo e backup e
la levità grati ma alimentazione treno
deragli anni fa tabula rasa da sono
intestinale che non è niente di grave ma
è un passo dalla retto politica pausa ed
è giovane non può mica gli scavi moglie
da un giorno all'altro per cui vi prende
due scatole di aumenti di 225 uno al
mattino dopo la colazione ma stomaco
vuoto nella sera non prima della cena ma
dopo la merenda plaudo 500 è prima che
il gallo canti due volte dopo la seconda
equazione del giorno l'act of florence
quel giorno con almeno 6 litri d'acqua e
facendo teca prevale mentali ndoja se
non ha capito tranquillo tanto toma
tutto scritto qua sono 385 euro più iva
fuoco che ha fuori arrivederci